[Música]
ustedes sabían
que el 65% de las muertes anuales son
adultos mayores a 65 años
esto me hace pensar en mi amiga andrea
un día llega a la casa de su abuelita
toca la puerta y nadie le responde
desesperada por sola chapa y al entrar
la encontró tirada en el pie del
barandal
su abuelita había pasado la noche en el
suelo después de haberse caído por las
escaleras no tuvo tiempo para levantarse
ni fuerzas
y quedó allí tirada toda la noche
mi amigo sergio perdió a su papá
producto de un accidente
el señor propuesto con un buró que lo
hizo precipitarse al suelo y se lastimó
la cabeza
lo encontró la señora que le ayuda a
hacer el quehacer al día siguiente
ahora imagina que eres tú
que un día te levantas a las 3 de la
mañana sin querer te tropiezas y quedas
en el suelo tirado adolorido
no hay nadie que pueda ayudarte y peor
aún nadie sabe que necesitas ayuda
y es que estas historias no solamente
son verdaderas sino que cada vez son más
frecuentes
ustedes sabían que para el 2050 la
expectativa de vida será de 81 años
de acuerdo al último censo del inegi hay
al menos un adulto mayor por familia y
un alto porcentaje de adultos
económicamente activos esto significa
que cada vez hay más abuelitos
y son millones los abuelitos que no
quieren ser cuidados que se sienten una
carga o que sencillamente no quieren que
los vigilen
el problema es que este 65% de adultos
mayores que mueren representa cerca de
430.000 personas fallecidas
ahora bien
que hicimos ante esto porque tener una
persona que monitorea un adulto mayor es
caro
y a menos que tenga conocimientos
especializados como una enfermera o como
un paramédico podrá hacer algo en el
tiempo de una crisis para todo lo demás
ese cuidador solamente podrá avisar a
las personas oa sus amigos oa su médico
y seamos honestos nosotros somos la
próxima generación de adultos mayores
los famosos millennials ya rondamos los
treinta y tantos lo que significa que
antes de lo que nosotros pensamos vamos
a necesitar cuidados especiales entonces
quisimos ante esto
a construir el primer robot hospitalario
de mexico
no me malinterpreten ya había robots
pero estaban enfocados al área académica
o al área de investigación
ningún esfuerzo comercial
mis socios y yo somos cibernéticos y
como buenos amantes de la tecnología
queremos solucionar todo programando el
aire su luz surgió un día en que estaba
comiendo cereal y escucho mi hermano
micky decir estaría padrísimo tener un
robot que te ayude a saber qué hacer
cuando volteó a ver de qué se trata en
la pantalla aparece ando supersónicos la
famosa robotina obligaba literalmente a
su dueño a bañarse para ir a trabajar
qué pasaría si alguien obligara
bueno ayudarán a nuestros adultos
mayores a tomarse la medicina cuando se
la tienen que tomar agendar la cita con
el doctor que si hubiera algo raro en
sus signos vitales nos avisará a sus
familiares o al doctor o sencillamente
que les recordara sus pendientes en ese
momento agarré mi celular le hablé a mi
socio y le dije wey tenemos que hacer un
robot
ya habíamos pensado en hacer algo
disruptivo una vez que viendo un póster
de ironman
se nos había ocurrido ser un derviche
pero tener una pieza física de hardware
era mil veces más atractivo piénsenlo
bien nuestras generaciones crecieron
viendo en el canal cinco películas como
volver al futuro la guerra de las
galaxias' terminator
y todos estábamos esperando las cosas
los carros voladores
y los robots inteligentes
yo todavía no sé cuándo vayan a llegar
los carros voladores pero los robots
inteligentes ya han llegado les presento
a room y voto el asistente personal
[Aplausos]
y es para mí un honor
que reunimos nos acompañe
porque en el camino se han quedado otros
robots como ha ido como kurt y que
aunque eso es nuestra competencia
internacional lo decimos con tristeza
porque nosotros más que nadie en méxico
sabemos lo que es desarrollar y
comercializar tecnología de punta
si nosotros hubiéramos sabido lo difícil
que era esta carrera tecnológica
seguramente no lo hubiéramos pensado dos
veces porque desde ese momento hasta hoy
nos hemos enfrentado a un sinnúmero de
retos
por ejemplo el primero es que cuando vas
a desarrollar algo nuevo no hay datos
que investigar generalmente cuando la
gente se va a meter en un negocio no va
a meterse en un negocio pues busca que
otros esfuerzos se han hecho en este
caso no había porque nadie había hecho
lo que nosotros queremos hacer y estoy
raro pensando que méxico es la cuarta
potencia de robótica a nivel
internacional el problema es que son
robots industriales o académicos o de
investigación
una vez que nosotros decidimos y nos
dimos cuenta que vimos que íbamos a
hacer algo que nadie más había hecho nos
tocó reclutar más locos igual que
nosotros pero con especialización
técnica a dividir no había obviamente
porque nadie había hecho lo que nosotros
queríamos hacer
sin embargo logramos juntar un equipo de
personas que nos apoyarán y justo cuando
pensamos que habíamos elegido la persona
correcta ese ingeniero
se robó el primero prototipo
un día sencillamente no llegó lo fuimos
a buscar a su casa lo fuimos a buscar a
su voto trabajo lo fuimos a buscar a
casa de sus papás le hablamos por
teléfono y sencillamente desapareció
llevándose con él la inversión que
llevábamos hasta ese momento
para acabarla de amolar nosotros
queríamos utilizar la inteligencia
artificial de amazon cuando fuimos a
hablar con ellos nos dijeron que no
estaba la versión en español y que no
estaba dentro de su plan entrar a
latinoamérica eso nos obligó a nosotros
a hacer nuestra propia inteligencia pues
que creen
ya anunciaron que entran a méxico con la
versión en español pueden creerlo
bueno de esa experiencia el ingeniero
que desarrolló la inteligencia
artificial tuvo que salir por un tema de
salud de la empresa y entonces llegamos
al 2017 sin prototipo con la
inteligencia artificial incompleta y sin
dinero
sin embargo
nuestro compromiso y nuestro objetivo
era muy claro si o si íbamos a ser los
primeros en desarrollar el primer robot
mexicano porque creemos que la
tecnología está hecha para ayudar a las
personas estamos convencidos que podemos
cambiar el status quo incorporando
robots en los hogares pero sobre todo
queríamos ser los primeros en acercar
esta tecnología a las familias mexicanas
estamos seguros que si ponemos a room y
voy a cuidar a nuestra población
vulnerable no solamente les vamos a
hacer la vida más cómoda sino más
sencilla y más útil cuando ruby
y yo los cuido
por eso para el inicio del 2017 nos
acercamos al ex presidente de la
federación de robótica mexicana le
platicamos nuestra idea le pedimos que
se uniera a nuestro grupo formando un
equipo con gente de su confianza nos
acercamos un ángel inversionista que de
hecho se llama ángel miguel ángel y
comenzamos de cero pero con más
experiencia el tema del equipo lo
resolvemos reclutando por valores para
trabajar en room y necesitas dos cosas
uno tener valores morales es decir
actuamos de buena fe y dos estar
comprometido con el proyecto ya los
conocimientos los vamos adquiriendo en
el camino
después íbamos construimos un equipo
multidisciplinario formamos algún plan
de trabajo donde establecimos tiempos
entregables calendarios todo que íbamos
a seguir al pie de la letra
no pasó el dinero se acababa los
entregables no llegaban la funcionalidad
requerida no se lograba fue entonces que
llegó el campus para ir del 2017 y nos
obligamos a estar allí contratando en un
espacio para obligarnos a estar en la
que sería la feria tecnológica más
importante del año pasado
logramos estar allí mostrando a robot
1.0 porque no queríamos hacer el
ridículo y trabajamos a marchas forzadas
con muchos errores de codificación pero
ya como un prototipo funcional nos
salvamos de esa lo que siguieron fueron
las eventos también para nosotros
obligarnos a participar
después lo que seguía era validar con
los adultos mayores fue entonces que nos
encontramos con lo humano
revisamos ciertas premisas validamos
algunas hipótesis revisamos el producto
mínimo viable y entonces nos jugamos
nuevas cartas fue así que nació ruby bot
en términos comerciales con una alianza
que hicimos con ibm para utilizar la
inteligencia de watson y con una alianza
que hicimos con samsung para utilizar su
nube en el internet de las cosas
este chiquitín
ya anda
haciendo de las suyas este año estuvo en
el congreso panamericano de retina y
vítreo en la feria de telecomunicaciones
próximamente en el festival
internacional de cine en multimedios y
la semana pasada acaba de ganar el
premio del the mighty technology review
a nivel latinoamérica es decir este
chiquitín ya anda haciendo de las suyas
y además le gusta decir chistes oye rumí
cuéntame un chiste
qué hace un perro con un taladro
taladrando
yo por mi parte tengo dos cosas que
compartirles la primera la tecnología
se tiene que masificar y poner al
alcance de las familias porque está
hecha para ayudar a las personas en la
segunda si nosotros hubiéramos sabido lo
difícil que es construir algo desde cero
hubiéramos comenzado desde antes porque
se necesita mucho esfuerzo mucha
voluntad y mucho compromiso
bueno aquí estamos como buenos mexicanos
nos lanzamos como cri link contra
freezer cuando rubén a lo bestia
pero viéndolo en retrospectiva era la
única manera de hacerlo un día marcus
dantus el dueño de estatut méxico nos
hacía esta analogía generalmente cuando
vas a boxear primero te preparas
entrenas haces tu dieta te ponen los
guantes te subes al ring y peleas
ustedes se pusieron los guantes y se
subieron a ponerse en la madre con
canelo
sólo resta ver cómo les va en este round
pues bien no vamos a tirar los guantes
porque sabemos que rumí bot te ayuda a
envejecer dignamente cuidando a los
adultos mayores y quitándoles de
independent dependencia que tienen con
sus cuidadores haciendo sobre todo que
no se sientan una carga pero sobre todo
no vamos a tirar los guantes porque
estamos convencidos de que rumí bot nos
dará la calidad de vida que todos los
mexicanos merecemos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]